non respect de la concurrence invasion
de la vie privée abus en tout genre
jeff bezos ce tim cook sundar pichai et
mark zuckerberg se sont fait sermonner
par les politiques lors de ces auditions
un peu spéciale par écran interposé les
élus américains ont livré leur avis sur
ces mastodontes et leur position de
toute puissance
beaucoup des pratiques de ces
entreprises ont des effets économiques
néfastes
elle décourage l'entrepreneuriat
détruisent des emplois augmente les
coûts et dégradent la qualité pour être
clair elles ont trop de pouvoir
que ce soit à travers l'internalisation
du fils d'ordre la pratique de prix
d'éviction ou l'obligation faite aux
utilisateurs d'acheter des produits
supplémentaires les plates formes
dominantes ont usé de leur pouvoir de
façon destructrice et nocive afin de se
développer
le président donald trump lui-même à
exposer clairement sa position juste
avant le début des auditions affirmant
que si le congrès ne forçait pas les
gaffes à être équitable il le ferait lui
même avec des décrets au fil des
questions google et facebook ont été
pointées du doigt pour s'être accaparé
l'essentiel des recettes mondial de la
publicité en ligne amazon com apple ont
eux été accusé d'être juge et partie sur
leurs plateformes respectives à moins de
100 jours de l'élection présidentielle
de nombreuses questions ont porté
également sur les réseaux sociaux et
leur rapport à la liberté d'expression
les patrons ont eu peu d'opportunités de
répondre aux accusations mais tous ont
joué la carte sensible de la success
story à l'américaine en appelant à la
fibre patriotique du congrès je suis
parti d'un emploi stable à wall street
pour fonder amazon dans un garage de
seattle en sachant très bien que ça
pourrait ne pas marcher j'ai
l'impression que c'était hier que
j'emportais lé paquet à la poste moi
même rêvant qu'un jour on pourrait
s'acheter un chariot élévateur
l'obsession du client a conduit à notre
succès et je considère comme un article
de foi que les clients le remarque quand
vous faites les choses bien
9 l'industrie technologique est une
histoire de secret story à l'américaine
les produits que nous fabriquons ont
changé le monde et améliorer la vie des
gens
notre industrie est l'une des façons
dont l'amérique passage ses valeurs avec
le monde est l'une de nos meilleures
exportations économique et culturel
liberté innovation mise en avant de leur
contribution à la croissance et aux
créations d'emplois aux états unis
les gars fassent se sont défendus
d'écraser la compétition si l'audition
par la commission judiciaire a peu de
chance d'avoir des conséquences majeures
elle pourrait néanmoins servir de
tremplin à la mise en place de loi plus
contraignante pour les plateformes
numériques